[Music]
foreign
[Music]
not to give a real introduction into
Quantum Computing because that by itself
will take more than an hour and I really
want to focus on why Quantum Computing
is relevant for existing and new
Developers
and um
I don't think there's another way to to
start then by comparing Quantum
Computing with classical computing
So In classical Computing we have the
concept of a bit classical bit is uh
either zero or one
and everything in classic Computing is
based around this concept of bits we can
do operations on bits and we can concat
them in in a byte and we can have a
string which is basically a combination
of bytes we can do
arithmetic we can do operations on bytes
in the end it all comes down on simple
operations Gates applied to
bits for example
um probably the simplest operation that
you can think of is the the not
operation and not applied to zero
returns one in Java for example you can
see this concept by having a Boolean
that we assign the initial value of
false
and then the second Boolean bar is the
negation of uh the first Boolean so that
will then be uh two so that is that is
very simple how classic Computing is uh
working we have SIMPLE bits
in um
Quantum Computing
um we have also bits but we call them
qubits there uh sort of the equivalent
equivalent of quantum uh bits
and similar to Classic Computing the
operations in Quantum Computing are done
on one or more qubits before we are uh
going into more detail about what a
qubit is let's have a look at
um a game in Java so I will now start
the Mary had a little qubit
game and we will show some of the code
so this is again uh Mary walking around
there so you can still go to the barn
but when she goes there
um she will get only one sheep at the
time just to make things uh easier
and I changed the the Sprites or at
least the the meaning of the the
different parts in this game for example
um you see at the bottom right that you
can press X H or C to activate or
deactivate Gates these gates are quantum
Gates so it's the equivalent of quantum
Computing of classical Gates but then
apply to Quantum Computing for example
when I press the X
you see that the chicken coop is now
highlighted if I press X again it's uh
disabled and if I press X again it's
enabled again so this gate is now active
if Mary works with the lamp to that gate
you will see that that lamp will change
it's now uh black and not white anymore
and at the top of the screen you can see
a Quantum circuit
um you don't need to know
um anything about that circuit right now
just be aware of that memory is now
working with a qubit so that that is a
bit it used to be zero which is white
and now it is one
if Mary goes to the church
you see that the value at the church is
currently zero she comes there with a
qubit that was in the State uh one so
the total value that's now in the church
is one
and we can create a string of two qubits
for example
and if we go with those two lamp qubits
to the chicken coop they will both
become
one so we now have the representation of
1 1 in in binary one one is the three in
decimal so if Mary goes to the um church
again
the number of our qubit string is uh red
and added to the church so one plus
three is four
so that is uh um so far nothing special
that's just
um that looks like classical computing
the only thing is we do it with qubits
instead of bits but so far there is um
no difference let's go back
to the slides so the qubit that we
showed until now is zero or one similar
to the classical bit
but the qubit can also be a combination
of 0 and 1.
and that sounds strange so so so how can
something be a combination uh between a
combination of zero and one that is um
counter-intuitive it should be either
zero or one as you could see in the game
the the lamp was either black or white
but not gray
so how can this be possible with qubits
now before we answer that question let's
first think about what is actually
um a bit and what is a classical bit
and in um classic Computing a classical
bit is
zero when there's no current allowed or
one when there is current flowing
through a transistor so there's a
physical component that determines
whether
um
a bit is zero or one so there's a direct
analogy between the hardware world and
the software world
and that is actually
um the same in Quantum Computing there's
a direct relation between a physical
representation of a qubit and the
software representation of our qubit
so we'll first
mention the number of possibilities that
allow to create a physical qubit
and then I will show how it's
represented in software so physically a
qubit can be a superconducted circuit or
a photon or a trapped ion or an electron
with a with a spin
and those representations or concepts
that are come from quantum physics that
are known to be
that can be in a superposition in a
combination of two different states
and what is this without going into
um into a physical detail
let's take a simple example well simple
of an electron and you may have heard
that an electron has a property which is
called a spin
and the spin can be up or down and it's
uh um it's related to how the electron
is uh moving and in this spin up
corresponds for example with the number
one and it's been down corresponds with
the number zero so if the electron is in
spin up
that is actually sort of a qubit with a
value one and even electron is in spin
down that is then a qubit in um with
value zero
but the spin can the electron States can
be in the combination of spin up and
spin down
and that
means that until we measure
the value of the spin
there's a chance that we will measure
spin up and there's a chance that we
will measure spin down and this is
really one of the Core Concepts of
quantum physics this is not this does
not mean that
um it's either spin up or spin down and
we simply don't know it yet no it's uh
proven that this is
um really a combination of two spins
and
um I have to be careful about the
wording because some people are very
um picky about how you call this but
um
sometimes it's said that
this Effect one has been up and spin
down at the same moment
um there's discussion about whether you
should use a term or not but I often
think that for developers
you don't need to worry too much about a
physical background so if you want to
think about it that this electron is has
spin up and spin down at the same moment
and I I think that's that that's fine
but the terminology that we're using for
this is that
um this is this is in a superposition
State a superposition means that
um we have a combination of two base
states here so it's one and zero at the
same moment maybe there's at this a
picture for example you can see that
there the the arrow going up is larger
than the arrow going down so maybe if we
measure it we might have maybe 70 chance
to measure one and thirty percent chance
to measure zero but
until we measure it it's both
so there are a number of
different possibilities
for representing a qubit in Hardware
trapped ions erect movement has been uh
subcompact insert for example with a
Joseph from Junctions
in the software world we simply called
it the qubit and I'm very glad to be in
the software because
um I um I really think that the the
hardware is really the amazing part
because realizing Quantum Hardware is
extremely difficult and in software we
can make abstraction of this we simply
assume that it's there and it's up to
the hardware Engineers to well to bring
it there but that's an incredible
achievement that they are doing
so um what is the current state of a
Quantum software well
you can't buy a quantum computer from
Dell at the moment or you can't go to a
Radio Shack or and and buy a Quantum
mobile device or so so so those quantum
computers are not widely available there
are some prototypes there are some
commercial uh implementations uh for
dedicated uses or more General usage for
example companies like IBM we get a
d-wave they have those and they provide
access to those quantum computers
and often this access is provided via
the clouds so you can subscribe to a
cloud service and then you send an
application to the cloud and that's then
executed on um one of the quantum
computers in the cloud that is not very
easy for developers if you have to test
your application by
um sending the execution requests to a
cloud service where you have to wait
until one is available and so that
that's uh that doesn't really scale
it's a um it reminds me of uh when I was
a student that we had a Mainframe and
you could write your program and then
submit it to the Mainframe and um and
wait for the result to come back
the next day or so
um the good thing about that was that
you were forced to think very hard about
your application because
if the debug Cycle takes one day you
have to think uh very hard about uh
before you submit request but
fortunately the situation now is
different because you don't need to
um to use a real quantum computer to
write and test Quantum software because
the quantum Hardware can be simulated in
software
there are some restrictions because
the software simulation is much slower
than the real Hardware
but that's typically okay because the
most of the work that's currently being
done with Quantum computing is related
to experiments and uh and trying to find
out which algorithms would be uh really
beneficial for uh Quantum uh Computing
so it also allows you to program in a
more higher level language like Java or
python for example instead of
going low level and talk about the
quantum algorithm Quantum Gates which
are more complex it's it's a bit like in
classical Computing you program in a
high level language and not really in
machine language
so um one of the quantum software
simulators that you can use is strange
which is a Quantum Computing simulator
written in Java where I'm the lead
developer for
and it contains of actually two layers
so the top layer provides Quantum apis
at a high level
and they are accessible to Java
developers and you don't need to know
much about Quantum Computing it's just
that they will internally use lower
level Quantum properties and Quantum
algorithms to achieve the results
and that lower level is then
also accessible for developers so if you
want to use that lower level you can you
can do that by programming uh to the
lower level apis
and with strange you can currently
execute your applications
um on your own localhost on your own
laptop or desktop and you can also
um and that's what I'm working on right
now use a cloud-based simulator one of
the reasons for this is that
um as I said a Quantum simulator is
slower requires more memory so for
bigger tasks it's often beneficial to
offload them to a cloud
so um comparing the high level apis and
the low level apis
the high level API is uh well one of the
examples is a function called random
bits and that will give you a random bit
so that doesn't sound very useful but
it's uh it's very good to as an
introduction into Quantum Computing and
the key Point here is that we only use
Java types here so uh this function has
no parameter but it returns an INT which
is known to Java developers another
function that's part of this high level
Quantum apis is a search function where
you provide a list of elements that you
want to search into and then a function
that
Returns the element that you actually be
searching for this is an implementation
of a gross algorithm which allows for
searching a list leveraging Quantum
properties
which will make it much faster than if
you would have to iterate over all the
elements in a doing it in a classical
way but you don't need to know anything
about how it is actually done because
everything that you see here this um
parameters that are passed to the
function are purely Java parameters
existing parameters so a list a function
an integer that's all standard Java so
you don't need to know anything about
Quantum Computing if you want to
leverage Quantum computing
however it helps and it's fun
um the main reason why it helps is um
it's it's it's good to to understand why
some algorithms are applicable to
Quantum Computing and why orders are
less applicable and at a low level API
in strange
is using Gates like the harlemar gate I
will come to that immediately or the X
gate which is the the not gate or the
conditional not gate and that uses
Quantum types and if you want to use
this API then you need to know what
you're doing strange so that Quantum
simulator is an open source uh project
you can go to GitHub
relfx Quantum strange and you can find
the source code there and it contains
some information
about how to build it if you would like
to build it and how to run some samples
so well maybe
um I can show the website
so this is a strange it explains how you
can get started with a very simple
program so this is how you can use
strange this is a simple Java
application you can create a program a
Quantum program add some steps and add
some gates to those steps and then
execute the program and measure the
results so this is using the low level
Quantum apis I will at least show the
high level Quantum apis as well well
actually I can show them right now
um I open
netbeans and there you see the code of
strange
so this is the uh the strange project
loaded in my IDE and there's a call uh
class classic which provides some of the
high level apis
and so the method that I showed on the
slide is the random bit method it
returns and it returns a random number
so that's actually the first use case
that I describe in the book How can you
return a random integer in Java with
Quantum Computing that sounds
totally unuseful well actually it's not
because this is really if you apply this
to real Hardware this is really
purely random as random as it can be
at least with our current understanding
of quantum physics
um and that is
useful in security and so on
the implementation of this method is
using the low level apis as I said
before so in this implementation we will
use things like a program like a step
Hardware which is one of the gates in
Quantum Computing so this is really
doing the the real Quantum work it will
do this in a Quantum execution
environment
which is uh just an interface while
while I'm here I can probably show this
interface
which allows you to run a program and a
program is then a Quantum program
um the simple Quantum Computing
execution interface that we're using
here
is simply using your Local Host bit
um
the same application that you are using
uh that you're writing can also use for
example a cloud Quantum Computing
execution environment
and it would be nice that in the future
when there's real Quantum Hardware that
you can keep your programs and you just
change the quantum execution environment
to to real uh Hardware or so
um
that is not for tomorrow
um but
um that doesn't matter too much uh to
you as a developer I often compare it
with the um the Y2K bug the millennium
bug we knew that at the year 2000 that
some of the existing computer software
would stop working
because of uh
um well issues with how the the uh the
date was stored
and it took a long time before all the
software was updated and you didn't want
to wait until it was really
um 2000 before you started working on it
so therefore it's very useful to start
working with simulators before
um uh real Quantum Hardware is there
because then by the time that Quantum
Hardware is available you will have your
applications ready